en troisième ils ont deux jours pour
réaliser un film de 3 minutes sur
l'écologie pour ces 5 jeunes entre 16 et
25 ans le cinéma était un rêve qui est
devenu aujourd'hui réalité alors il
touche à tout lactine m'intéresse
beaucoup mais la réalisation aussi c'est
quelque chose qui m'intéresse beaucoup
mais je me rends compte au fur et à
mesure que je participe à des tournages
que c'est quand même assez compliqué
c'était vraiment très sympa
oui beaucoup mais c'est un mal pour un
bien il faut toujours perfectionner le
truc et franchement ben j'aime beaucoup
j'ai un très bon groupe l'énergie il est
au top comparé à d'autres groupes
moi je suis plutôt dans la photo dans
l'image du coup vidéo j'aimerais bien
filmer et trouver des plans sinon dans
le make-up artistique tout ça les décors
et l'active là je vais essayer pourquoi
pas pour voir là on entendait ça
descendre ambiance et ensuite on
trouvera des bruitages pour vraiment
alimenter les actions que font nos
acteurs dans le court-métrage ça
travaille un peu oui beaucoup j'ai
toujours été intéressé par le cinéma
vraiment le les métiers autour de ça et
tout et pouvoir aujourd'hui à la Réunion
découvrir ce métier et bien c'est
vraiment une chance qu'on a et
franchement moi j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion grâce à cette expérience
c'est graines de réalisateur se
découvrent des talents se former avec un
format réduit c'est tout l'intérêt d'un
court-métrage le court métrage se
développe parce qu'en fait il y a deux
jeunes réalisateurs qui émergent donc et
comme
la porte d'entrée dans le cinéma c'est
forcément court-métrage c'est forcément
un format qui a de plus en plus de
succès qu'à menace développer c'est pour
ça que nous on passe par le
court-métrage à cinécourt pour faire
émerger justement de nouveaux talons
apprendre ensemble en s'amusant et sans
trop de pression rien de mieux pour
conforter leur passion qui deviendra il
l'espère leur métier
[Applaudissements]